john o'sullivan is a man of many gifts
being used in many locations around the
world he is president of the Danube
Institute based in Budapest the Danube
Institute is an independent center of
intellectual debate for conservatives
and classical liberals and their
Democratic opponents in Central Europe
he is also editor of quadrant magazine
and Australian based periodical a senior
editor at large and columnist at
National Review magazine where he served
as editor from 1988 to 1997 senior
fellow at the National Review Institute
and co-founder of Washington DC's
think-tank 21st century initiatives
previously he served as Radio Free
Europe and Radio Liberty's executive
editor he has served as a senior editor
at the London Times and The Daily
Telegraph and in the British government
as a special advisor to Prime Minister
Margaret Thatcher Mr O'Sullivan has also
been editor-in-chief of United Press
International his book the president the
Pope and the Prime Minister has been
translated into seven languages and he
was made a commander of the British
Empire in 1991 please welcome John
O'Sullivan
yes risk putting that there for the
moment um Madame chairman distinguished
guests ladies and gentlemen old friends
may I begin by thanking you madam
chairman for that very generous and over
full introduction the older I get more
astonished I am to listen to that long
list of my former jobs was there really
an associate editor of the London Times
how come I did nothing about his
outrageous anti conservative bias it
reminds me of my mother's reaction when
she heard an equally generous
introduction a few years ago yes she
said John just can't seem to hold down a
job well it's a particular pleasure to
speak to a Hillsdale College audience my
first visit to Hillsdale was in 1976
when the college plays played host to a
meeting of the Mont Pelerin society that
was attended by coincidence by a large
delegation of people who had come
directly from that year's Republican
convention needless to say they were all
disappointed
Reagan delegates but though disappointed
they were not despairing one of them
said to me that after hearing Reagan's
great address to the conventions last
night when he stole the show from the
nominee President Ford he knew the man
said he knew that something important
not something historical but something
almost anticipating history had just
happened that night he said to me we
lost the election we asked the
nomination and we're probably going to
lose the election
but since that night I've known that
Reagan is going to be President how he's
going to be president I just can't see
it looks impossible but I know that he
is going to be President and that I'm
absolutely convinced well a few months
later after the election had been lost
Pete Hannaford who I think would be a
friend to many people here rang up Mike
Deaver in California and told him that
citizen Reagan had been told by a hotel
manager
that sums hotel staff would like to meet
him before he left that day Regan
graciously agreed
he always did really expecting to meet a
few conservative stalwarts but when he
went downstairs he found the entire
hotel staff have lined up to shake his
hand as if he were a monarch on a state
visit Hannaford said to Deva this is not
an exact quote I'm afraid Mike something
has happened to how people feel about
the governor it's not just Hollywood and
not just his governorship somehow they
see him as a president now I have no
doubt that that change of sentiment
among ordinary people towards Regan not
one
ock echoed by the elites or the media
was in part the result of his conversion
convention speech that year at a low
point of his fortunes he demonstrated
his own visionary greatness and his own
patriotic faith in the American people
at a time when all of America was
watching on television they saw then
what pope john paul ii later called
reagan's noble soul and their view of
him changed that's a lesson to all of us
not simply for apprentice statesmen
whatever the next few months holds
politically we all have a duty to
represent the conservative best in the
American Dream and not its occasional
descent into nightmare the whole world
may not be watching us but those around
us will be and they will remember what
we do recall the words that Margaret
Thatcher used about the president at his
funeral
she said we have one advantage Ronald
Reagan never had we have his example and
today as other days but the times to
follow it now my second visit to
Hillsdale was for another Mont Pelerin
meeting at which Hayek and Friedman both
spoke I'm pretty sure their topic was
the free market and I'm pretty sure they
were in favor of it
and madam chairman by Jove so am I not
millions but billions of people who were
starving 30 years ago and now living
middle-class lives around the world
because of the free market revolution
brought about by Hayek and Friedman
Reagan and Thatcher those billions are
buying American goods and services and
some working people and some cook
businesses in America and Britain have
lost ground and suffered some
displacement some unemployment as the
result of the side effects of this
revolution and I think more will do so
in as a result of the coming automation
revolution too we have to devise ways of
enabling them to adjust and benefit from
this economic progress that lightens
labour and rewards effort and ingenuity
conservatives are for all Americans not
simply the coupon clipping classes and
corporate managers but we don't want to
close down the engine of prosperity
simply because it doesn't reward
everyone equally Milton we would say
three things we don't confuse free both
of those that was the first the second
is we don't confuse free markets with
open borders Milton Friedman didn't he
thought you could have open immigration
into a welfare state like ours or
Europe's and we shouldn't either we
undoubtedly need new economic thinking
to deal with new economic challenges but
we don't need anti economic thinking I
think these I also might add to that a
third or fourth proposal we shouldn't
confuse free trade with managed trade
agreements particularly those which try
to avoid democratic control
so I am for free trade I am for control
of immigration and I am for a sensible a
sense government that tries to help
people to help themselves to deal with
crises in their lives that have been
created by developments that are on the
whole beneficial now my third visit was
to speak to Hillsdale was to speak at
the unveiling of the Margaret Thatcher
statue that the campus now has it was a
little unnerving to speak with herself
looking over my shoulder but I fortified
myself with one of her Twelver them I
would say I fortified myself with a
glass of her favorite scotch but but in
fact it was one of the I provided myself
with one of her favorite reflections one
oddly enough that she shared with me
with the Maynard Keynes at the she
called this Thatcher's law the
unexpected always happens the inevitable
never and and ladies and gentlemen that
the election campaign has demonstrated
the truth of that again and again I also
recall it by the way that another
speaker at that unveiling it was a
friend also many here today namely Pat
Sajak the much loved a much respected
television host who had decided to come
back to college to get a further degree
I think that's admirable and so would
Margaret Thatcher
maybe Americans don't know this but Lady
Thatcher was an early supporter and
later the Chancellor of the independent
University of Buckingham which is the
nearest equivalent to Hillsdale in the
United Kingdom it requires I know this
is it requires enormous dedication and
commitment to preserve a college with
the higher standards when it has to
compete with the taxpayer supported
unlimited funds of the state system or
the vast bequests of the Ivy League that
dedication that commitment they are
doubly necessary when we see the
extremes of corruption cowardice and
anarchy into which the
state system and the Ivy League colleges
have descended in the last few years if
in them this year particularly on a
personal note here I think I may be the
first visitor to took to Yale
this happened 20 years ago and to be
attacked by a howling mob of PhD
students it happened when I spoke on
multiculturalism and I had to be rescued
by the police and but but nothing
terrible happened except of course it
was terrible that Pete that students
particularly advanced students should
not should feel that they had to
suppress points of view which were well
sufficiently respectable to be the lead
article in that week's magazine so we
are deeply in the debt of those like
president Arne and the Buckingham
trustees who not only sustained a great
liberal University but actually runs
serious academic outreach programs to
give citizen voters a better
understanding of their nation's history
and traditions so I hope that other
colleges will follow your example and I
hope many others will follow mr. Sajak's
example I will confess by the way that
that day when mr. Zajac spoke I was
hoping he'd enrolled at Hillsdale
because he had ambitions outside
Hollywood and was doing prep so to speak
oh yes Hollywood conservatives are
always complaining how tough life is for
them and how they faced political
prejudice from liberals but I take that
with a pinch of salt statistics show
that one in three Hollywood
conservatives one in three goes on to
become president of the United States
now now the title of my talk is how
people around the world see the November
election or something like that I didn't
actually choose the title usually I
followed the example of Ronald Reagan's
first great national address in 1965 and
call all my talks rendezvous with
destiny it suits every occasion every
topic you can call it brexit rendezvous
with destiny for Brenda or rendezvous
with destiny the globalization
imperative but by Robert Ludlum it adds
tone to a speech it has a touch of class
even if it gets less plausible with
every passing year that destiny has
arranged a rendezvous with me unless
it's the name of a young woman on an
erotic Lee themed website but on this
occasion the title might seem to be the
APA's ID mr. German looking at the
November election and the term ology is
produced particularly the term all is
produced within the conservative
movement I wonder if this will be the
very first talk on conservative my ever
given that leads to a barroom brawl in
the audience until recently the idea of
a fistfight between the editors of
National Review and the Claremont
Journal would have been more or less
inconceivable the editor fistfight
between the editors of Chronicles and
Commons we know we can imagine that but
things have come to a pretty pass when
half of the conservative movement is on
what we might call no speakers terms
with the other half because one of them
might vote Republican today senior
conservatives are cutting each other in
battalions in the public square as
beyond the city walls the drumming's and
new relations of the alt-right fall
ominously on the night Reagan's 11th
commandment thou shalt speak no ill of
another Republican has been thrown
overboard it should all make for a
terrific debate but not really a very
effective election campaign consider
first not the Pacific until it occurs
that emerged in the primaries in the
Trump and Sanders campaigns particularly
but the overall feel of the race today
the serious issues that emerge in the
primaries nationalism economic
protection political correctness a new
less interventionist foreign policy
whatever you think of them they have
been overshadowed
if not obliterated by the antics the
gaffes and the plausibly alleged crimes
of both of both campaigns maybe the best
metaphor for the race to date is one
that Donald Trump himself has used the
fixed fight on this occasion however it
looks as though the mob has blundered
and bribed both candidates to take a
fall
so they stacked so they stagger around
the ring
sorry their Integra around the ring
hurling loud blows at each other but
leaving their defenses wide open
suffering their fall blows of equal
noise and they've eventually fall back
exhausted into the arms of their staff
trainers each seems to be fighting but
and to lose in his or her distinctive
way mrs. Clinton is being undermined by
the continuing drip drip drip of her own
emails that show her to have lied and
broken federal laws during and and since
her time as Secretary of State
Trump is being derailed at intervals by
his own gaps and insults such as most
recently his alleged Fatima not most
recently but just recently his alleged
fat-shaming
of a homicidal gangster's moll whom he
wants to employed comparatively
respectively as a beauty queen
fat-shaming being worse crime today than
gangsterism and attempted murder
in the eyes of feminism in the media the
Clinton campaign has taken good
advantage of this and began promoting
the beauty queen and bitter one can see
why the beauty queens
excusa Tory motto we all have a past
would appeal to the Clintons
but as this week is also shown to Donald
Trump - both candidates are now
embroiled in an ugly dirty and vulgar
disputes that unfortunately have no way
of being settled the the charges of
sexual battery against Trump and Hillary
is covering up Bill Clinton's sexual
assaults are both plausible and also
unprovable beyond doubt that means they
just drag on indefinitely
so both presidential candidates are now
two of the most distrusted people in
America
each overtakes the other at intervals
depending on whether her lies or his
gaffes dominate the headlines Clinton
has the current advantage because
Trump's alleged groping has captured
recent headlines and because the media
biased beyond even the generous
standards of an official communist media
in the Eastern Europe
because the media has played down the
recent WikiLeaks exposure of her
campaigns mixture of cynicism and a
religious prejudice one has to say that
may well change in the I'm not the
biased but the issues it may well change
in the light of later events there are
four full weeks of hyperactive
campaigning and a final presidential
debate between - between now and
Election Day
so as my title asks how does all that
strike the rest of the world well the
short answer of course has to be that it
strikes the rest of the world as
exciting and entertaining but neither
serious nor hopeful as a sort of well it
strikes it a bit like a soapbox version
of the well not I was going to say not
yes Prime Minister
that's comparatively sober but the west
wing or what's the the the British show
that became an American show it slipped
my mind now yes house of cards yeah yeah
I mean that even has a murder in as I
remember and we may be going in that
direction of it but but the thing is
that but they are American elections
always by the way I when I worked for
Radio Free Europe the all of the East
Europeans who and and the Soviet people
who have X are we people who work there
they all were fascinated by American
elections because they are genuine
elections you don't know what's going to
happen a lot of their countries you know
exactly what's going to happen back down
to a percentage decimal point but but
the fact is there's this is a real
democracy which is what makes its
election so interesting but they also
strike people they also make foreign
observers say things like this is
America anything can happen here it's
the kind of tabloid country much more
troublingly when the foreign media tries
to you know beneath this surface and
convey the serious matters at stake they
tend to repeat the liberal
interpretations of what paul johnson
calls the sevlie Dedan certainly seven
deadly sins The Times The Post Time
Newsweek and NBC CBS and a bee
see in America the monopoly of
interpretation that these news media
used to enjoy has been significantly
undermined by talk radio Fox News the
social media and other insurgencies but
the washington press corps is still
unduly influenced by only in the foreign
press core is still unduly influenced by
the legacy media and peter basel maxim
sorry i'm peter basel maxim what matters
in today's world is not the sound but
the echo is something that's still very
important in transatlantic transmissions
so when Sir max Hastings was asked by
The Spectator what he made of the
election campaign he replied that if
Trump wins it will be a mass retreat
from reason so Max himself as a moderate
conservative and he quoted other
moderate and intelligent people such as
the historian Michael Howard whenever
Sir as expressing the same or similar
views a Google search would would
multiply those names right across their
political spectrum
I will sum up their collective wisdom
here as arguing that the election itself
is a carnival of irrationalism that
Hillary candidate Hillary Clinton is a
bad candidate and a dishonest politician
but a more or less safe and orthodox
Prudential president that Trump is a
reckless and unpredictable demagogue
that his supporters ill-informed
and Prejudice voters who have fallen
victim to a dangerous populism in short
the American electorate is irrational
ill informed in populist and the more
thoughtful foreign observers conceived
that the same evils can be seen in
Europe in brexit in Poland in Hungary
and in the rise of populist parties
throughout their own continent
ironically of course it is the foreign
observers who are inevitably
ill-informed they are drawing on a
narrow range of sources for their
opinions mainly the the Meuse papers I
mentioned and those sources do not
include their own experience ordinary
voters route their views in that
experience among other things I would
say the weakness of mrs. Clinton's
campaign
among others is that she has closed her
ears to the experience of many voters
especially white former Democrats on a
range of issues like black lives matter
and anti-cop violence and she's done so
in the interests of arousing her base
among minorities by making the maximum
possible demands Donald Trump on his
side seems to me not always to
understand the issues such as
immigration control and protection which
the vote in which which he has exploited
and went and which the voters are
definitely worried about because of
their experience my feeling here is
others may differ is that Trump
blundered into these anxieties while
campaigning and found himself gaining
support more than he expected as a
result of responding to them eventually
he adopted their policies to deal with
them and found himself winning the
primaries but he changes his positions
now and then and it's reasonable to
think that he hasn't fully worked out a
plausible set of policies to deal with
the matters he's discussing in other
words if you look at what the foreign
observers say they're putting the blame
not first and foremost on the candidates
whom they think are responding to
popular concerns but on the voters so
are the voters to blame did they push
the candidates into extreme positions
are they irrational
populist racist David Blankenhorn the
president of the Institute of American
values found he didn't know a single
person who favored Donald Trump so he
decided well I also know I'm the
president of the Institute of American
values I also find out what are the
values of masses of Americans in
particular the people who support Trump
um he spent two weeks driving around
America's southeast
my home incidentally I live in northern
Alabama and talking to whoever would
talk to him the results an article that
quotes extensively from ordinary
Americans talking about Trump and
Clinton are to be found in the current
issue of the American interest and they
are well worth reading and pondering
among other things he found that Trump
voters far from being irrational were
very realistic occasionally even cynical
about Trump those who supported him most
strongly did so
because they liked the fact that he
wasn't bound by political correctness
when he spoke about immigration and
other issues
he spoke about them as he saw them they
said paradoxically some of the same
people that was supporting him disliked
his insults to other people they
disliked his use of profane language
they disliked his inability to control
his own mouth they thought these were
false and the faults were needless and
damaging but they liked what one might
call his political profanities all the
same many of them were skeptical but
Trump would do what he promised they'll
succeed even if he tried but they
thought that he was much that sorry that
but they thought he was much more likely
than any other candidate to try these
things and just succeed if he did on the
whole they had a low opinion of all
politicians and little deep hope of
electing a good government it was merely
that Trump offered something better than
the establishment polls polls as one
supporter said what's the worst thing
that can happen he doesn't do what he
says he's gonna do I've seen that for
the last thirty years in fact that's not
the worst thing that can happen alas but
it's still an eloquent comment on the
last thirty years where their comments
racist well I don't think so but you can
read Blanken Hall's article and judge
for yourself one one had mild criticisms
of black Americans working in the health
field but he was a dying man as he said
and perhaps somewhat more critical and
difficult than usual and other was
critical of Muslim immigration and its
effects but in the main the distinctions
these voters made between Americans were
rooted in politics and in social
position for more than race or religion
these people are fearful about the
future and they have an acute sense of
loss they feel that the America they
have known and loved is being taken away
from them and replaced by something
worse they might not use the term but
they are losing they think they are
losing top villian America with its
trust habits of trust and social
cooperation most of them incidentally
were not badly off they went on drugs
there
alcoholics and they weren't unemployed
somewhere of course in short there were
not members of an underclass left behind
by history and economic progress but
ordinary working or retired Americans
who lived at one level or another in the
great American middle class if they are
dispossessed of anything they are
culturally dispossessed are there than
populace or attracted by populism
not if the usual meaning of populism
namely that there is a deep vein of
wisdom in the common people not if that
definition has any force almost all of
them were totally realistic in their
assessments of people including
including Trump and about their own
hopes to the future what they asserted
and what many people are mistake for
populism is that there is a deep vein
they thought there was a deep vein of
arrogance and stupidity in the elites
Trump's people don't glorify themselves
but there are contemptuous of the elites
that have governed America for the last
few decades they especially distrusted
Hillary Clinton Blankenhorn could not
find a single person who liked or
trusted her at the same time they didn't
see her as someone very different from
those governing them now she was simply
the most representative person of the
kind of elitist progressive politician
that they have come to dislike and fear
so let me put it this way both in terms
of policy and philosophy on the one hand
and in terms of personnel on the other
there is a major issue before the people
at this election that may be concealed
at the moment by the sleaze factor Trump
voters and the u.s. electorate more
broadly are neither irrational nor
racist nor populist but they are
overwhelmingly hostile to the kind of
interventionist controlling liberal
progressive internationalist government
that in their view has governed them
badly for a long time and which refuses
to listen to their complaints
they are also that they sorry and and
they are also well they had the same
attitude to the national and
international elites that they see as
the supporters Onan and enablers of that
kind of government they see the divide
in US politics as one between well I
could give it several definitions
globalists versus nationalists elites
versus the voters democracy versus
oligarchy they see their own elites as
joined to of elites internationally the
whole Leviathan metastasizing at home
and abroad and when foreign observers
have gotten over their enjoyment at
mocking American elections they too
recognized exactly the same divide in
their own politics and in brexit in
central Europe's resistance to Brussels
in the growing popular opposition in
Germany to the acceptance of millions of
Middle East migrants and in the
anxieties everywhere about massive
social change organized by governments
and global bodies that don't bother to
consult citizens and voters about it or
if they do don't do anything when they
get the results this divide is
recognized increasingly by political
writers and events such as brexit and
the rise of Donald Trump have forced it
on people's attention it has elicited
from conservative writers in particular
a series of sometimes surprised
sometimes profound usually shrewd and
almost revolutionary reflections on the
nature of this division and its
consequences across the board those
writers include the Polish statesman
philosopher Richard the gut Co in his
book at the demon in democracy Walter
Russell Mead on the American interest
blog Israeli editor Yoram has oniy in
mosaic my n our National Review
colleague is Ramesh Ponnuru and you 11
who point out in depth and in detail the
constitutional threat that Hillary
Clinton posed poses to America's
traditional Constitution John Fante of
the Hudson Institute in his critiques of
global governments and
his book submission or sovereignty and
that fellow with the with the Russian
name in the Clermont review I can't
remember Seneca I hope not Petronius
because I was reserving Petronius for my
internet rendezvous with destiny that
doubtless I have missed other important
analyses in my Australian exile though
someone else who has contributed
mightily to the critique of legal
transnationalism his professor James
Allen of Queensland University to my
mind however your amaha Ruggero not
forgive forgive my pronunciation
Yoram Heusen he has given us the most
comprehensive account of the clash
between two visions of national and
global order let me quote it what we are
seeing is the beginning of a struggle
over the character of the international
political order itself for 350 years
Western peoples have lived in a world in
which national independence and
self-determination were seen as
foundational principles see among other
places by the way the Declaration of
Independence indeed I'm continuing with
has only these things were held to be
among the most precious human
possessions and the basis of all the
evolved their freedoms since World War
two however these intuitions have been
gradually attenuated and finally even
discredited especially among academics
and intellectuals medium opinion makers
and the business and political elites
and I would say particularly so in in
Germany today many in the West have come
to regard an intense personal loyalty to
the national state and its right to
chart an independent course in the world
as something not only unnecessary but
morally suspect they no longer see
national loyalties and traditions as
necessarily providing a sound basis for
determining the laws we live by for
regulating the economy or making
decisions about defensive security for
establishing public norms and/or for
deciding who gets to live in what part
of the world that's the end of their has
an equal now tonight is not the occasion
for a full taxonomy of the many
different ways in which this clash plays
out across the range of economic
little foreign and constitutional policy
for that
read the right as I mentioned but one
aspect deserves to be singled out that
of democracy which flourishes only in
the nation-state and which cannot really
survive in post national organizations
which do not have a link they are not
accountable to voters anywhere and have
and have to confess again and again to a
democratic deficit a democratic deficit
which even when acknowledged by them
somehow never gets filled in um it was
borne in on me during the brexit
campaign that the leave campaign wanted
above all to recover Britain's status as
a self-governing democracy while the
remain campaign wanted to avoid
discussion of that point at all costs
that is continued in the post brexit
aftermath in which recidivist uranus
have sought to blame brexit on popular
ignorant populism racism and anything
but what the levers said plainly was
their main ambition one american critic
former US ambassador to germany john
Kornblum illustrates this point writing
in the same issue of the american
interest as David Blankenhorn he says
look at the key calculation that
affected the brexit vote it was about
how much dole the European provides to
depressed Rust Belt areas of Scotland
Wales and England as against what
Britain pays into the common pot the
whole idea is that the future of the
United Kingdom should be decided on the
basis of such objective economic
weakness and calculative pandering
beggars belief
unquote well what truly beggars belief
is that anyone should believe such
nonsense I do not deny that economic
arguments were used on both sides of the
campaign but the economic arguments in
the in that campaign well overwhelmingly
from the remain camp they invariably
predicted economic disaster if it went
through but those arguments were
rejected by the voters indeed they were
rejected by the very voters who
according to ambassador Kornblum would
have been most hit if the predictions
had proved accurate it was the Rust Belt
areas of economic depression
Britain that voted most heavily between
sixty and seventy percent for leave
maybe they disbelieve the predictions
and if so they were pretty right on the
evidence so far but the evidence is
stronger that they were voting to
recover and safeguard their political
rights and liberties how can we explain
the inability of a distinguished
diplomat to see what's in front of his
nose one reason I think is that
globalists judged the value of political
discipline decisions less of a political
decision less by its results than by its
provenance if it's taken by a global
body it's assumed to represent virtue
and efficiency if it's taken by a
national government it's thought to
represent selfishness and anarchy
globalism gets the benefit of every
doubt because it allegedly represents
the future although the idea that a
leads know what the future holds should
have taken a complete knock in 1989
now one shouldn't be dogmatic decisions
taken by national governments are
sometimes wrong see smoot-hawley and my
own view is that simple protectionism is
usually counterproductive but few
national decisions have had such
calamitous consequences as the
collective EU decision to launch and
sustain the euro if that persists today
because it is because it's not really
subject to the democratic verdict of any
particular European nation it is upheld
by a post national euro establishment
that has only a remote connections with
accountability and the and the voters in
a world of post democratic globalism
major decisions will increasingly be
made in that way and increasingly
sustained whatever their apparent
results who will decide such questions
in the United States Washington or such
globe or some kind of global coalition
is the underlying issue in this election
mrs. Clinton whatever her faults and
virtues is plainly a determined
globalist as President Obama has been
Donald Trump is plainly an opponent
now I think it's a historical tragedy
that this decision has been overwritten
by the question of both candidates
fitness for the presidency it seems
evident to me
others will differ that neither is the
best representative of their cause but
there is no good reason to prefer mrs.
Clinton to Donald Trump on the basis
that their personal and moral moral
fitness I could put it no higher than
that but I would say that one of the
things that the old Trump has
demonstrated is a willingness to take on
the Clintons in a straightforward tough
way which very few other politicians
frate afraid of their power have been
prepared to do it may well be it is only
a politician of the kind who has some of
the faults of Trump who would be
prepared to do this let me put it this
way it may be the kind of campaign that
only it may be that only a camicazi
campaign can actually dent some of the
self-sufficiency and self-satisfaction
of the Clintons and of the kind of
politics they represent as has any point
SAP sorry well actually the questions
are coming so you can throw you can
throw the point at me well well I can't
hear you but but I'm sure that's an
interesting point but
but I mean I'm gonna take questions as
hasn't he points out no matter what
happens in November the political fault
line has been uncovered at the heart of
Western politics and it's not going away
the politics of the democratic nations
are rearranging themselves along this
fault line new candidates for office
perhaps more appealing than Trump
perhaps less so we'll take up one or
another version of the same cause with
consequences we cannot now predict if
conservatives finally need advice on
what to do here they can find it I never
expected to hear myself say this in an
article in the American Political
Science Review it dates from 1956 it was
written by the late Sam Huntington and
its title was conservatism added as an
ideology conservatism huntington held
was that system of ideas employed to
defend established institutions when
they came under fundamental attack when
the foundations of society are
threatened the conservative ideology
reminds men of the necessity of some
institutions and the desirability of the
existing ones and when something like
the French Revolution comes along says
Huntington men are driven to
conservatism by the shock of events by
the horrible feeling that a society or
an institution they have approved of or
taken for granted may suddenly cease to
exist what is happening today that most
resembles the challenge say of the
French Revolution any answer must be to
some degree speculative but my own is
that the next great challenge can now be
seen in the gradual undermining of
democracy and the shift of power and
decision-making from institutions
accountable to the voters to those that
are either accountable to no one but
themselves or that inhabit a
constitutional limbo where they cannot
easily be held to account we see the
harbingers of this challenge across the
first world in three developments the
shift of power from legislatures to
bureaucratic agencies and the courts
brought about by over government the
shift of power from nation states to
Trouper national bodies and finally the
development of anti-democratic ideas
that lagging behind events served to
justify the
relatively new political practices and
to defend the new loci of demo of
undemocratic power that is the that is
now the battle today I happen to have
written those words in 1998 but this is
the first time since then that we have
been given a clear chance to vote
against this threat to our institutions
our democratic institutions in our two
countries
whatever our doubts however reasonable
our doubts I don't believe we should
pass up the opportunity to vote for the
candidate who is determined to stop this
thank you
is there any other any questions let me
take change my glasses it's no better
yeah
thank you any any questions oh that's
very satisfying answered all questions
in advance trim yeah oh it's a question
here
hello I'm Maurice Norwood I'm from
Dallas Texas and when you start off your
speeches talk about free trade
agreements etc having been a person who
have read CAFTA NAFTA and numerous other
smaller trade agreements and then now at
least portions of TPP which I don't have
to read the rest I would to understand
what it's about and then obvious about
free trade none of it is about fair
trade there's only about 5% about trade
then of witches to the benefit of of the
American people second of all you
brought this is once again early on I
should have it going with a hundred
questions but you talk about well Reagan
and certainly he's a better president
than a bike that we've had around but
let's never forget that Ronald Reagan
was the first person to give amnesty to
illegals and then we had a whole number
of smaller
amnesties and now we're continuing on
our nation without borders and we
continue down this whole land the
progressive movement that started long
ago and that everybody moved to thank
you just happened today
yes it doesn't please come in sir yeah
absolutely I'd be happy to by the way I
think I'm going to comment more on your
remarks and immigration than on on the
the kind of trade agreements we have
like NAFTA I think that frankly they are
so specialized that I I would prefer to
have somebody take the general
principles that we believe in one of
which would be for example that dem that
they could that trade agreements
treaties can't override state and
federal government but on immigration
yes was Reagan responsible for the 1986
immigration control act he certainly he
certainly bore responsibility for it so
did the Senate and and the house and so
on
he himself read his Diaries that this is
Alma this has almost made nothing of but
the
the senator on the Republican side who
was most active in in putting that bill
through I'm tracking of his name he was
from Colorado know what's the bill
Armstrong it sorry no it was a
Republican and anyway though point is he
was a conservative Republican he was an
intelligent man and a good man and he
pushed through this as part of a deal
which in which would have been okay
we're now imposing yet Moulton Simpson
that's right it's we're now imposing
controls more effectively will stop
future immigration and the cost of that
is to try just to give acceptance to the
people who are here
Reagan has a meeting with him around
that time and says I in the diaries you
can see it so I saw I saw senator
Simpson here we had a drink he's
absolutely right we've got to stop this
unlimited immigration his bill give us
an opportunity to do this decently and
so on and so forth there is no doubt
that he wanted that Reagan wanted to
control and regulate and reduce
immigration is equally no doubt that in
retrospect that failed completely
it failed partly because people did not
understand that if you've got that first
of all more people would be legalized
then people thought in advance I mean
the the numbers who applied turned out
to be larger and secondly that there
would be with the Democrat with the
direction of policy and sympathies in
the Democratic Party there would be no
support for can't for enforcing the
restraints that judges would but I mean
immigration control is laughable in this
country as a matter of fact I mean
unless you're an immigrant as I am we've
gone play by the rules and I mean then
you you have to you have to do what you
told you know you all probably know the
work of mark Stein well mark was
employing someone in the who was an
immigrant in his little organization and
he said um I got a call from the
immigration control office and he was on
the phone for about an hour answering
all their questions
eventually said oh there seems to be
under some you've seemed to be under
missus um misapprehension the young
woman who works for me it's not a legal
immigrant which she was really not
illegal she's an illegal immigrant and
the guy said oh oh well okay thanks no
we needn't bother about that and and in
a way that seems to be official
government policy so your criticism of
Reagan is in part fair but it is is in
based but I think Reagan and anyone else
of that those opinions given the
knowledge since that we have accumulated
since then about the way immigration
control is actually run would not of
would not have signed that bill and
indeed the the immigration control in
practice has got increasingly lacks from
the moment that the sixty-five bill was
passed let alone the 86 bill and there
has to be I mean obviously this election
is among other things an eruption of
anger in the majority of the American
people against this and a wish to do
something about it and both in your
country and in Britain I think it's fair
to say that the ordinary people are not
hostile to immigrants they are hostile
that those who are criminals of course
but they're not hostile immigrants
they're hostile to the idea that they
don't own this country and that anyone
is entitled to come here who wishes to
do so without benefit of law and I think
that that of that feeling is a perfectly
legitimate one in fact it's
indistinguishable from a normal respect
for democratic and national sovereignty
any other questions
oh yes there's a question here thank you
are you gonna hold it okay we often talk
about the electorate being more fully
informed and I wonder if you have some
suggestions about how the electorate can
be better informed because we have more
information sources today than we ever
had is it just a problem of they know so
much that isn't true
you remember that famous quote from a
former president but how can we as a
country better inform about the issues
and where the candidates stand on those
issues I don't think you're going to get
people who have reasonably Pleasant
lives and there is and who have so many
distractions in terms of popular
entertainment to want to become
professors of political thought and like
that's not going to happen now the the
bare rudiments that we used to be able
to get across and we used to be able to
get across a fair amount in in public
schools and in private schools actually
I mean the when I met my grandmother
left school at 13 my mother left school
at 14 my father at 14 they were very
well educated people you know and and
yet I when I was last working in London
I had the secretary who was a graduate
from Oxford and she couldn't she
couldn't spell she couldn't punctuate
her you know so what is happening when
the major universities are receiving
people who've got good marks in high
schools who can't you know who have to
be given remedial education the first
few months they're there because they
don't know the basics something I mean I
know that that's not true for everywhere
and I know that there are some very good
schools and we've recently had an
improvement in education in England I
think you have here in your case with
charter schools and in in our case with
the new forms of independent schools
which created by the parents and and and
subsidized by the government
these things are very important these
changes are important we need to recover
a good education for all of our children
and I don't know anybody who doesn't
agree with that everyone thinks it's
true but it doesn't happen does it now
there are many reasons why it doesn't
happen but one of them is that the
politicians particularly in the
Democratic Party are in hock to the
teachers unions and the teachers unions
I'm not saying that they are actually
hostile to children's education though
doubts about that but they those but the
teachers unions are certainly don't make
the education they give the principal
thing it's the protection of the
teachers which is their principal
concern and and that often leads to
schools keeping on bad teachers who work
they would very much like to to to fire
and replacing them with better and
replace them with better teachers but
they're not allowed to do so under the
under the deals that the teachers unions
have and that the teachers union
monopsony is rooted in the public school
monopoly we need to find some ways I
think from an economic standpoint
breaking up education monopolies as a
way of getting a better service from
education I don't see and it seems to me
the simple how do we get a better
educated electorate we give them a
better we make available a better
education you can see the appetite in
the voters for education in the sale of
books about the American history and the
founding fathers in the appetite for
television programs of this kind they're
ordinary people no very often that they
should know more and they want and they
try to find they try to get more and
they spend their own money to do it but
you can't expect kids who have never
been given the grounding to and which
fortunately college like Hillsdale gives
you can't expect children who never been
given the grounding in in American
constitutional history and the meaning
of the Declaration of Independence in
the importance of the Constitution and
in case of Britain similar institutions
and
- if they don't have the basics they're
not gonna go further down the road of
learning about what's going on and in
politic and then there will be very much
the potential victims of people who
offer them that much too simple and
dangerous ideas and most of those
dangerous ideas which which damage
politics and damage their young holders
come from the left they don't come from
the right have to question well I'd like
you to continue this comment I see not
immigration illegal immigration are
thrille threat it's two issues one
illegal voter registration two people
coming from radicalized countries like
Somalia Middle Eastern countries that
have the red the jihadist predominant
theory that drives them please comment
well it's obviously I mean it is
obviously the case that anybody who
comes into America should be able to
demonstrate their respect to build a
respectable background and a willingness
to abide by the American Constitution I
mean that was something which
traditionally America insisted on if you
go back and read books about America
like for example Chesterton's book on
America after he'd been here he came
back and he said you know of course
America is a different kind of place to
England so he said take take come over
on Herbert the anarchist writer the the
police never got go to they don't think
of arresting mr. Herbert in order to
prevent him throwing a bomb at the Queen
because they know that mr. Herbert is a
Tory [ __ ] whatever is anarchist
opinions and he would never dream of
doing anything against his sovereign and
they don't they don't investigate the
activities of mr. Herbert Spencer the
the libertarian writer because they know
that
whatever is political opinions mr. mr.
Spencer is a a nonconformist of the old
school and he would never dream of being
violent towards anybody but he says
that's not that's because they know
Herbert Spencer and they know over on
Herbert now the customs officer the
immigration officer in 1911 having
millions of people streaming in he
doesn't know what these people are so to
speak like he hasn't know anything of
them so um he has to ask them questions
like him are you coming here the
intention of overthrowing the American
Constitution of course not likely to get
an honest answer but but nonetheless
those kind of questions were asked and
for most of my life I remember people
being told that you couldn't if you were
a communist you you'd be asked if you
were a communist if you were foolish
enough to say yes they wouldn't America
wouldn't let you in and that was as I
say understandable in a nation of
immigrants
in which lots and lots of people are
coming in from whom you whom you met
whom you have no idea what they are like
and therefore you have to in a sense
investigate now that seems not to be
done now in the way it clearly was done
during the period of the Great Wave of
immigration and in the 50s and 40s and
50s during the Cold War it obviously has
to be done in some way but it the more
people who are invited in or allowed in
and the harder it is to do and it's
particularly hard to do if the
authorities can't say well who do you
know in Mogadishu who can vouch for you
and could I have his phone number
because now that's done by the way in
that's often done but it's harder to do
when you have very large numbers coming
in and you have a breakdown of order in
Mogadishu because the old play when you
could ring up you know American
University in in Beirut and say look I'm
a bit worried about this fellow do you
have any information for me is just he
doesn't does he seem that as a kind of
chap we should have him and yeah you
could do that but you can't do that now
it's just physical it may not even be
legal such of the rules these days but
also it's
simply not practical in the way that it
would have been once so it's under you
you obviously have to get control of
immigration to the absolute minimum
degree that you don't allow people in
who intend to do you harm it seems to me
that's clear I think you had other
questions but that's the most important
one